Eine rote Zipfelmütze,
festes Schuhwerk, ein weißer Bart –
und die Laterne,
denn er schuftet im Bergbau.
Das ist er:
der Original-Gartenzwerg!
Und hier steht seine Wiege:
in Gräfenroda in Thüringen.
Die Gartenzwerg-Manufaktur Philipp Griebel
ist eine der letzten in Deutschland.
Herrscher in diesem Zwergenland
ist Reinhard Griebel -
und zwar schon in vierter Generation.
Sein Urgroßvater Philipp Griebel
gründete das Unternehmen 1874.
Von seiner Werkstatt aus brach der Zwerg
zu seinem globalen Siegeszug auf.
Er stammt aus dem Bergbau –
als Nachbildung der Bergmänner,
als Symbol des Fleißes.
Und im Bergbau hatte man
eine Zipfelmütze auf.
Und diese ging natürlich etwas
über diesen Schulterbereich,
damit kein Gestein reingefallen ist.
Der Kopf ist normal groß,
der Körper ist etwas gedrungen.
Es sind kleinere Menschen, und im Bergwerk
brauchte man die kleinen Menschen -
und deswegen auch
diese Zwerge als solches.
Zunächst wurden Modelle
für verschiedene Berufsgruppen produziert,
zum Beispiel für die Metzger
als Schaufensterdekoration.
Mit Schaufel und Schürze tauchten sie erst
Mitte des vergangenen Jahrhunderts
in den Privatgärten auf -
zuerst in den deutschen und später weltweit.
Immer als Symbol für Fleiß, obwohl sie doch
nie wirklich bei der Arbeit helfen konnten.
Die Produktion der Gartenzwerge
in Gräfenroda
hat sich in den vergangenen 100 Jahren
kaum verändert.
Die Figuren aus flüssigem Ton
müssen einige Stunden trocknen,
bevor die Nähte mit einem Schwamm verputzt
werden.
Anschließend werden sie bei mehr als
1000 Grad Celsius gebrannt.
Erst danach werden sie von Hand
und mit viel Geduld und Liebe bemalt.
Und das könnte die Zukunft der Zwerge sein:
eine Geburt im 3-D-Drucker.
Den Plan dafür gibt es einfach im Internet
zum Herunterladen.
Zum Beispiel für Karl –
aktuell das Maskottchen der
Bundesgartenschau in Heilbronn.
Dort steht er quasi
als der Gartenzwerg der Zukunft.
Er verbindet Tradition mit moderner Technik.
Die Digitalisierung
wird unsere Städte verändern,
wird unser Leben verändern.
Und deshalb passt unser digitaler Karl,
glaube ich, ganz gut in diese gesellschaftliche
Veränderung, die im Moment vor uns liegt.
Der frische Wind kommt
vielleicht gerade recht,
denn viele Deutsche wollen gar keinen
Gartenzwerg mehr im eigenen Garten.
Er gilt ihnen als Inbegriff
von Spießigkeit und Kitsch.
Weil Gartenzwerge
echt ’n schlechtes Image haben
und ich wahrscheinlich so ’n bissel …
der ist mir peinlich.
Mir hat sich also der Sinn eines Gartenzwergs
bisher noch nicht erschlossen,
ich hab‘ allerdings auch noch
nicht viel Zeit dafür verwendet.
Ich hab noch [ein] paar Erbstücke,
die setz ich halt in die Ecke,
aber ich würd‘ mir jetzt
keine mehr kaufen.
Dabei ist er einfach typisch deutsch.
Noch immer tummeln sich
Millionen Zwerge im Land.
Zurück nach Gräfenroda.
Veronika Jäger bemalt die Zwerge
hier schon seit mehr als 30 Jahren.
Sie liebt sie auch im eigenen Garten –
nur nicht zu viele.
Wenige Auserwählte dürfen sich dort
verstecken oder bei ihr faulenzen.
Der Liebling ist mein Felix,
der Liegende, weil mein Vater so hieß.
Und der wurde so genannt –
ausgerechnet, weil [es] ein besonders
Schöner mit einem sehr,
sehr schönen Gesicht [ist],
und dadurch ist das mein Liebling geworden.
Aufträge hat Reinhard Griebel
übrigens immer noch viele.
Bis nach Frankreich und Schweden
schickt er seine Zwerge.
Trotzdem könnte hier bald Schluss sein.
Der Ruhestand naht.
Heißt das, dass der Original-Gartenzwerg
jetzt vom Aussterben bedroht ist?
Ich geb mir große Mühe,
dass es weitergeht
mit den kleinen Wichteln
mit der roten Zipfelmütze.
Denn wenn man den Burschen
doch in die Augen schaut ...
Na, warum sollten die aussterben?
Das wär‘ wirklich schade drum.
Für die Manufaktur
sucht er deshalb einen Nachfolger –
jemanden, der sich auch in Zukunft
um die kleinen Zwerge kümmert.